got anything RIT I thought that was so
cute all right some of you assumed
stories last name was Scott after her
fell
oh my god ha ha ha
don't make me say so cute again Oh
crushing it today I got a little tangled
up hey
don't want a lot for Christmas there is
just one thing huh you mean tired guys
go asleep it's been a long season I
sleep here at the office looks like
there's a couple of a bachelor now we're
done that's it is it bad that I'm such a
believer great do think it's good all
this work is not my friend we met a lot
of characters in season one yes almost
Christmas is hilarious heartfelt in the
hollow of Halloween thanks on the
bug-head front we remain non existent
can you take that one more time
[Music]
whoa oh shoot I spilled it on my dress
oh well it's a rental three two one
hi I'm Deidre Behar with it sorry
happy birthday Jayla whoa that was
really aggressive I got this the 19 year
old is of course referring to her
Olympian father six kids and four step
kids with ex-wives Kris Jenner Linda
Thompson and Christie Christie Chloe
shared in a little father-daughter fun
how's the hair is there like any weird
rogue pieces thank you thank you oh I
see it I see it yeah I'm shedding are
your legs crossed yeah okay I don't have
to cross them okay that works no means
yeah well but then no yeah it takes my
shirt million subscribers have sometimes
meat to it don't you think
uh well we hope you guys enjoyed that
blooper reel because we seriously didn't
think that would ever see the light of
day so you're welcome but we aren't here
and we're here because of you so thank
you guys so so much for watching thank
you so much for subscribing and gear up
because things are only gonna get better
than here guys 1 million let's get to a
billion
[Applause]